you cannot say I don't want to I you do
want to argue you wanted to make your
point let me make it back Hannah and
then you're gonna try to say it's too
spicy for me no I got you like let me
respond to you it is not capitalism
coming in and enshrining enslavement and
in fact capitalism is what got rid of it
and started pushing back against this
centuries old awful institution so to
say it's capitalism I think it's
honestly offensive we are approaching
the 150th episode of middleground and we
need your help to continue making more
episodes join our middleground patreon
community and help us write the future
of Middle
Ground America would be a more powerful
country under communism may they agreer
step
forward I think it would be a lot better
for all the people who are working jobs
that are not I guess Tech basically so I
make content which means that I work a
lot of hours and I don't pay pay the
same amount as a soft Dev so I think it
would create more creativity in certain
like creative Industries artists if you
make a bigger pie everyone gets a bigger
slice yeah I think one of the main
misconceptions about communism is that
it's just making everybody equally poor
when marks and Engles wrote repeatedly
that the first step under communism is
increasing the productive forces in the
US over 80% of our population is living
paycheck to paycheck if you provide
people's basic needs if you invest in
economic growth and in jobs and in
infrastructure rather than investing in
endless war and massacring Muslim people
and Gaza you're going to make this
country a lot stronger you're going to
make the people a lot more stable here I
grew up in in a white ring area I grew
up in Denver Colorado was born in Dallas
Texas I'm the first American my family
everybody's from the Congo if my family
was able to come here of course it would
have some capitalist connection so I
grew up very much with the idea that
everything I need is under capitalism
individualism Freedom all these things
are under capitalism but I'm black in
America so those contradictions really
just created that friction where I'm
like this doesn't align with what I was
told and what I'm actually seeing or
actually feeling so why did I come to
Communism when I actually read it when I
went from from Marx to Lenin to to ma to
den to to Fred Hampton I started
realizing like oh this is patriotism
this is the idea that I look at another
American and think to myself I want you
to be fed I want you to feel fulfilled
in your life I want you to feel like you
actually have control within your
Society honestly as somebody again who
grew up in that rightwing area that
flies over everybody's
head disagreer are walking quick on this
one can I say can I say something first
on this one to be so uh bold here's my
argument how come every communistic
country has to build a wall or a fence
to keep people in China a letting people
out my grandma I remember going my
grandma but where did you come but where
did you come there's not a mass
immigration into Venezuela into China
into Russia where do people want to go
Switzerland America Sweden they're all
talking about we need to build a wall
because people are coming China's not
going well we better build a wall
because all those Americans are coming
across nobody's going there so you
legally cannot become Chinese I went to
Tado School growing up and every single
non-asian or anyone else that's like
American or Canadian that's gone to
China has never wanted to come back to
the US that's something that's really
interesting so I think it's like if
you've never been adverse selection a
group of people who are finish your
point and then I guess like Whoever has
the open mind to go visit usually
doesn't want to come back and I do live
streaming so I know a lot of live
streamers who like permanently move over
to the like Asia especially China
because not just it's cheaper it's also
just higher benefits most people get
like free healthare um so it's a lot
easier for you to survive there I think
it's not cuz people don't want to go
it's also because you're taught
propaganda since a young age China is
scary China's Bad Evil red dragon so
people don't go and don't even go see it
that's the problem I would definitely
argue that a lot of China's success is
due to the introduction of free markets
but if we want to run with this idea
that China is a socialist country which
is just fundamentally untrue I could
also just point the fact that they're
super low on the HDI their GDP per
capita is like 12,000 the US GDP per
capita
$70,000 um so like I I would say in
terms of like economic success we're
definitely doing way better Ty um in
terms of how we see immigration into
this country of course we're American
we're only going to see the American
viewpoints of this China has immigration
people do try to cross the China's
border all the time we're all humans
everybody's doing the same thing around
the world I would say what you're
thinking is a perspective issue I would
love to break it down even more and talk
to you about the massive amount of CIA
missions that have gone through Latin
America to destabilize those countries
but just at that point to what you were
saying judging a country by how much the
we Le people in their country profit in
their company we both know what GDP
means it's it's a b
expl about
HDI human development uh sorry human
development index so it's measured by
things like Health income it's the UN
standard for like how well an economy is
doing uh so from that point perfect
healthare we ranked 37 in the United
States Cuba ranks two
one wait wait wait CU ranks what Cuba
ranks what wait I want I really want to
engage number one and number two in h
three those spots
to according to the Commonwealth wait
wait wait Cuba Cuba is 83 on the HDI
they use their doctors like slaves
because 90% of the profit goes to the
state they literally traffic their
doctors when Bush opened up a program to
let Cuban doctors Escape because they
were trafficking them and making them go
do these PR campaigns in other countries
to give Healthcare 7,000 people
immediately came to the US at one
meeting two doctors passed notes to
other doctors they were on a hospital
set with and said kidnapped this is
appreciate I appreciate the emot
examples 100% it's not emotional you can
talk to the no border sovereignty
organization that works to get health
professional put the nicest person in
this room I I would hope you let me my
point and answer I got well I've been
told that fear fear fear fear fear is
happening in Cuba they're doing this
super super super scary thing with Cuba
which is great I would love facts so I'm
giving you facts about doctors fleeing
the country and also about how they
having ration basic antibiotics in their
Hospital yeah we've got them under an
embargo
medical
things true that's been disproven by
multiple studies this year during Co
Cuba made their own covid vaccine
because the the um us pharmaceutical
company used intellectual property laws
to prevent them from making this using
our vaccine recipe so they created their
own but they couldn't get syringes into
the country because of the Embargo
because how are you supposed to get
metal when you're on a tiny island
country and you're surrounded by the US
military Edie I want ask I want to ask
you a few questions how far back do you
think the Embargo is affecting Cuba how
long back do I think the Embargo
probably since it's been put
on no no no let me respond real quick
real quick in
1960 the USSR became the largest trading
partner with Cuba they started paying
more for Cuba sugar they they started
buying all of Cuba sugars and paying
more than the United States was paying
Fidel Castro is on record saying that
the Embargo had no effect on Cuba at all
so we can presume that up until 1991
when the USSR collapsed that it didn't
have an effect so to claim that the
embargo is
affecting and I think when we look at
the this can I make a point because this
is a point I wanted to make for a long
time when I when we look at countries
like Cuba and China I think it's more
important to judge them based on what
they had before the Revolution before
Cuba had a revolution nobody had access
to healthcare they were working on slave
plantations that were dominated by
Western multinational corporations China
before the Revolution yes there were
famines during the era of Mao there were
far more famines before came to power
and before China was able to
industrialize and get to the point today
where they're now one of the most
powerful countries on Earth in the 1950s
the US was already industrialized China
had to do that they were a semi feudal
country in extreme poverty and in just
70 plus years they've become this
economic superpower that is through
Central economic planning and yes
allowing some of those private markets
in fight undercutting the US on labor
because they don't actually have to pay
people very much they don't to pay them
based on their value so they can make
people come over there and work far
cheaper have their companies there and
then we buy their products cheaper we
are propping up China's economy and
we've been really stupid with our own
policies when it comes to that and also
we are constantly hamstringing ourselves
because our government keeps regling our
economy more getting more involved tying
its hands so that they are outpacing us
plus all the money we're spending on war
instead of actually like letting people
keep their taxes and invest in more
things so they they are playing us right
now the US has been really foolish but
it's not because Communism works they
were starving of mid 19 let's look at
exactly what they did let's look at
exactly what they did when they opened
up trade they opened up special economic
zones where multinational corporations
could come in but they said you're only
allowed to do things as long as it's in
line with the party and as long as it's
in line with the government's Central
plans I mean to say that China's just
capitalist full stop or that all their
successes come from Capital I'm saying
they were starving started they were
starving under feudalism Hannah and cam
come in here with the guns they got the
fire they know they're ready for
this um who is we when you say we who is
in this we cuz we did this cuz we did
that who is this who's this metaphorical
we because the US government is not a
capitalist government and we have to be
strict about terms here capitalism is a
system and an economy the government can
either uphold capitalism or they can
impede it our government is constantly
impeding it so when the government comes
in and tells you you can trade with this
person you can't trade with that person
that is the government which is we we
have a representative government doing
that is that something eyes a
capitalists want to see them do American
citizen we are American Citi we are
American citizens and so they are
supposed to be represented
our interest if we're going to talk
about what we're doing as a country yes
like that is a huge part of it and I
also want to go back to communism
because when you talk about some of
these countries that people often call
Democratic Socialist countries they rank
higher on the economic freedom index
than we do that means they are more
capitalist in their economy and I don't
think those countries are socialist to
be and so I just want to make sure we're
defined in terms because communism is
the centralized control and ownership of
production of company but this is my
point I'm trying to make like we have to
talk about
going def socialism to me it just it it
feels as very
demeaning how do you them because I'm
hearing things called socialism that
aren't but the prompt is communism I
guess like in terms of Communism and
capitalism both are ideal states that
don't fully work by themselves but I do
think capitalism is more pessimistic
versus communism more optimistic in an
ideal state if everyone actually worked
hard and they wanted to contribute to a
society to make it better I think
communism would work everybody cares I
think you guys are well in you could you
could teach them
though giving people government Aid
makes them
lazy getting government Aid makes you
lazy a great example of that is Elon
Musk the amount of government Aid the x
foundation gets in order to pursue
inventions that don't work how often did
you hear about that tunnel you want us
just one example of many different CEOs
multi corporations who get government
Aid to be able to do these thingss just
because they have the net worth I agree
with you on this I hate corporate
welfare I think it's the biggest
perversion of capitalism out there it
doesn't work it's track record is
terrible and it actually is the
government coming in and picking winners
and losers and it very rarely goes in
favor of small businesses which is what
most business in the US actually is
owned by but the way it makes people
lazy is not necessarily because they're
bad people it's because you have uh
fiscal cliffs you get this amount of
welfare if you make under $24,000 a year
you make $25,000 a year your benefits
drop off so it actually disincentivizes
people from moving up working harder
taking on more jobs and it's a terrible
structure I completely agree with that
from a perspective of it creates
animosity if there was um a system
saying that you can use a certain
government aid program that you're
already paying taxes to just because you
make this amount wouldn't you have
animosity for those people below you the
cliffs are are I think more so
specifically referencing like situations
where people are taking in welfare and
it it compensates for their like lack of
income and then they get a promotion or
something and they lose the welfare and
they're worse off than they were before
they lost the welfare and prior to the
promotion you build that state
dependency and it de incentivizes people
to like work up the corporate ladder in
their companies because they're
receiving aid from the government I
think also we have to say what makes
people work hard not just what makes
people lazy because I think that's the
problem you look at government welfare
is it is essentially keeping people
trapped it keeps them trapped in cycles
of poverty we actually saw before the
great welfare deal under LBJ was pushed
through we had a larger rate of people
coming out of poverty and moving up in
this country and then when we
implemented these programs that has
stagnated ever since and we can see that
that hasn't worked help me sorry just
help me out here real quick so when you
say it doesn't work uh what didn't work
we have not seen a decrease and the rate
of people who are in poverty and part of
this is based on the education system
part of this is based on different
because of L LBJ yes these programs that
came in the welfare I don't know this
because of it I think it's stagnated
work that was being done for me as
somebody who works in public policy
that's what I'm interested in what
works there are cases where I think
people are incentivized to work less
hard in order to keep their income under
a certain level so they can collect a
certain amount of you know government
money which in that specific case then
then yes I guess it does incentivize
laziness but also if you look at
government programs like Medicare and
Medicaid they're some of the most highly
approved of programs in in the country
and when you make a welfare program
Universal when you make it so it applies
to everybody it basically becomes
politically Invincible because nobody is
going to argue for their Grandma's
Health Care to be taken away and we have
a problem in this country where 45,000
people are dying every single year
because they don't have access to basic
health insurance and I think if we were
to nip that in the bud and nationalize
those giant pharmaceutical companies and
make sure that that Healthcare is
provided to everyone we would actually
stimulate a lot of innovation a lot of
Labor and a lot of hard work in this
country because people would be less
bogged down by medical bills and would
be more healthy in general so without a
market if those are if those the
pharmaceutical industry specifically is
nationalized how does the state set
prices
effectively
um before you get into that point did
you want to say something yes please
there you go I was going to add I guess
like I lived in China for 8 years and 10
years in the US so I have like the
Divide between the two I guess in China
generally speaking it's really safe um
and there's a lot more equality in
certain areas in terms of like uh
support from the government it is easier
to get Healthcare 100% And also I think
certain societies use communism well and
it can be used well to create I guess
more equality I think capitalism
ultimately creates inequality so one
thing I was going to say you have to be
careful there's an old saying we went
out of the fire into the frying pan the
question is under what system do you not
get the guys at the top becoming super
wealthy because Stalin and Mazy dong
these people be Chavez okay Castro this
man is No Angel the question becomes
which one dampens our greed in a way
that benefit the most people I don't
think it should be that it should just
be which system is more effective at
Distributing resources and helping
people have outcomes and China has
abolished poverty and we have rampant
China hasn't abolished poverty the world
there 300,000 homeless people in ratio
he said they abolished poverty there
300,000 wrote a full article onology
information when China was pure
communistic 45 million people starved to
death eating bark and dirt and leaves
and it's hard to know is it doing better
all the things you like are you sure
that's from the Communist side the mousy
dung side or is that from the capitalist
side I would argue it's definitely the
Am side I also just want to push back on
one thing real fast are we still gonna
stick with the China thing because
there's so many point great points here
need Focus you know mean it just it's
crazy me to hear somebody say China's
safer though and like you can literally
be disappeared from the streets like
even your celebrities famous tennis
players famous people they are
they out Julian
Assange shout out julan Assange but we
are not incarcerating Julian Assange
right now we are trying to EXT him here
for tri I'm doing our sitting in and
I've spoken out with I actually work
with his brother on the campaign to get
him freed but what I'm saying is we
don't have political prisoners in the US
we don't who are they who are they we
assassinate them
yeah who have we assassinated um Jal mon
was in jail for the government did that
I'm fine with this I detest the FBI I
detest most policing agencies I've done
a ton of work on Criminal Justice Reform
that's fun if I was a capitalist I would
love the FBI no I would love the FBI lit
literally literally the Vanguard of
capitalism 100% oh how's that it's one
of the Armed bodies of the state that
protects the the dictatorship of capital
cuz ultimately I mean 90% plus of
elections are decided by the candidate
who raises the most money FBI is an
armed body of capital would that well
you can say it's not real capitalism but
capitalism has a tendency to accumulate
all capitalism economic system right an
economic system that concentrates wealth
and power at the top that incentivizes
capitalists to accumulate Capital
monopolize the market targets and this
is simply the stage of capitalism that
we exist in when Iran tried to send oil
tankers to Venezuela the US intercepted
them with our military took them back to
Texas and then gave that oil to us
corporations how is that free trade how
is that the free market an embargo are
against yeah again I don't have to
defend the US government to defend I
would actually argue the US government
is a huge enemy of capitalism we don't
and I want to Define my view real fast
because I think it matters this is more
my like political view versus just my
economic views but I would say the only
reason you need a government at all are
for three things under capitalism and
that is to uphold contracts you need a
court system you do have to have a
policing system so that people cannot
harm other people's property or their
person and you need a national defense
system now what the US has has gone so
far beyond that we should have a defense
it should only be a government entity
you shouldn't have private companies
coming in and profiting off of it and it
should be on guard to protect us if
there's an existential threat not waging
more against other countries not getting
involved in all this interventionism
we've been doing since Vietnam
completely opposed to that but to sit
here and say that that's capitalism
that's the government actually attacking
capitalism that's coming in and
perverting our economic system using our
own tax dollars against us to do it
communism has caused more suffering than
capitalism has Jo a MGR patreon to watch
this exclusive
prompt women are more empowered in a
communist
Society here's a real really good book
on this called why women have better you
you want bunny to go first no no no go
ahead go ahead
go as a
man I'll be quick there's a really good
book by Christian Gody who is a woman
called why women have better sex under
socialism and other Arguments for
economic independence where she she's
very critical of the USSR and the former
Soviet countries but she says when women
have economic independence that equals
true Freedom um freedom to leave an
abusive relationship which under
capitalism a lot of women are forced to
stay in those relationships because of
financial dependence on their husband um
women are discriminated against in the
free market system because they have
babies women can get pregnant so if
you're a boss who are you more likely to
hire a good worker who's a woman who
might get pregnant for nine months and
have to go on maternity leave or a man
who's not going to get pregnant it's
just a a natural biological advantage to
men in in the free market so if you
provide economic independence for women
if you if you meet their their needs
that in turn equals freedom I read the
same exact book it's a good one uh the
idea that only theand be able to get all
the funds revenue for the family unit
the idea that it's a woman's job not
only to work as well but they but also
take care of the family at home I I
can't take a better example nuclear F
was literally forced onto Americans like
they had posts for everywhere like like
how's that how's that freedom so let's
say the US had 1 billion people how
would you do to limit population this is
the prime example right how would they
do it I don't think they'll do it any
differently than one child policy like
let's be realistic if you gave the US a
million people what are they going to do
they'd probably just let them starve
China they're like we got to ration good
to make sure we feed everyone circumstan
were slightly different they had to make
choices might not have been the best
choices but if given the same circum
sent in the US maybe they would have
done something similar communism in
China was truly communism in the
beginning so let's look at the beginning
um so my mom was really young during
that time but at least she saw what
women were empowered to do at the time
yes they took all resources and pulled
it together and divided it equally but
women were truly equal in the beginning
of China and Cultural Revolution women
had the same rights as men they did the
same jobs as men because more labor
they're better right so everyone had the
same roles same jobs um and there was
true equality until capitalism got or
socialism capitalism got introduced now
in China there's no equality I truly
think because more freedom more trade so
in the beginning when there was no
corruption it worked perfectly and
everyone was equal I think we have a
tendency to to boil down to disregard
economic freedoms when we talk about
freedoms especially in the US we break
it all down to individual freedoms what
do you have the right to do but in China
the retirement age for women right now
is less than 60 whereas in the US it's
been actually going up because economic
conditions for working people have been
getting worse I mean that is freedom
being able to retire and spend more time
with your kids less time slaving away
making your boss Rich that is true
Freedom women have equal rights in the
United States you are allowed to do the
same things that men do a lot of time
what happens with um like inequality is
not actually Market no no it's not the
market it's difference in preference um
specifically with like if you're looking
at like income inequality there are so
many confounding variables that you have
to look at when comparing income
inequality where do you live what's the
cost of living what kind of job do you
do what's the risk associated with your
job logically markets and capitalism is
uh the best resource or you kind of
prioritize the best right but if that's
the case women could get pregnant hence
they have to take time off hence they're
but that doesn't mean that they're not
the best at something despite the fact
that you can get pregnant they can still
be incredibly skilled over other people
but I think in capital Society is
because of that time unit to take away
it's a risk there are there sure there
are disadvantage there are biological
disadvantages final risks nobody's
contesting that there's a major
biological disadvantage for women women
can also choose there a communistic
country female leader yet Margaret
Thatcher New Zealand has one Finland has
one is there a commun Kim yo jong's her
name right in the dprk yeah she's one of
the highest up in the in country the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea
North Korea the US has had also had like
very high people actual
name the point is there's never been if
we're going to say communist The Prompt
was do
communist economies countries treat
women better so You' have no female
leader ever but you got to look at
averages though right no but that's
that's a bad average for you can I can I
have my
disagreement
because
listen I think it's a fair point in some
ways but also like as a woman I don't
want just to have like a tokenism kind
of representation like that doesn't if
Hillary Clinton became president it
would be no better for me as a woman
right so I don't that doesn't actually
Advance me but what does advance me are
civil liberties what do Advance me are
having the ability to speak my mind to
pick which career I'm going to do to
decide if I want to have kids if it's
worth taking time away from the
workforce or if I don't want to do that
the ability to have those freedoms are
here and yes there are many flaws and
there are things that that take away
from them in our society but as you
mentioned legally women have had
equality for decades and decades and
decades and now that we have seen that
time period play out women have been
advancing Leaps and Bounds they are
graduating college at higher rates here
than men they are starting to out earn
men when you look at Apples to Apples
when they have the same job same
education they're outpacing them in
their advancement within companies women
and men need the same things and that is
freedom autonomy the government not
getting in your way equality civil
liberties do you think economic
stability is one of those things that
women cve but you would say capitalism
is what gives ecomic stability even
though 80% of women are living paycheck
to paycheck it's still better than but
that's that's just relative poverty so
there's always going to be relative
poverty even if everyone in your
Society what relative poverty is
everyone there's always going to be
relative poverty in every society
because relative poverty is just
generally defined as making 40% less
than the median income there's always
going to be a median income unless
everyone's making exactly the same so
there's always going to be somebody
living in relative poverty but I want to
address something you said earlier that
we're like picking and choosing like the
US isn't capitalist here but it is here
no it's like you judge a country if it's
capitalist or not based on how it
expresses capitalist traits so we can
say that like in general the US is a
mixed economy that's pretty economically
free right but we can identify things in
the government that we don't like and we
can say okay well those things aren't
really expressions of capitalism and we
don't agree with them um so let's just
take three things let's take three
things are women treated better do they
Thrive more under a communist country I
think it's not only symbolic but it's
also reflection if you make a woman the
leader only capitalistic countries have
had women as the prime minister or the
president and there's lots of them right
now there's never been one in communist
history not even close Okay number two
yeah well America's not the only
capitalistic country you have Finland
you have New Zealand you had England had
keep going number two I think it's a big
deal that China massively
disproportionately killed female babies
it's a big problem and even they admit
it so when we say here's the system that
treats women better come on now the
third the third one that I think is
important is where do women want to live
well definitely not here okay sorry
where do they want do they want to live
in North Korea but North Korea is not a
communism though it's a uh which they
they just said they just corrected me
and
said
is Marxism leninism combined with Korean
nationalism that's their idea before we
get too far away from to into North
Korea real quick um just from the stand
not looking at the Constitution who
could vote who could participate within
the government within America using
America example rich white owning the
Constitution doesn't say that at all
democratically within the nation
actually taking control rich white
landowning males that was within the
Constitution and I used it's not sorry
it used to be it it was illegal let's do
a legal legal mandate women as well and
I Ed that as an example to show women
did not have rights within this system
at they fought for it okay aggressively
with violence to make sure that they got
their vote capitalism does not earn you
your rights especially if you're a
marginalized group because it's just not
profitable pay other people country the
country was established before like E
before like capitalist economic theory
was established and capitalist would
just argue look like nicest guy in the
world please let me finish this point
please cam
please God damn it
cam God damn it cam a
not bring my not a notepad need the
notepad cheating I asked only the rich
benefit from
capitalism uh really
nobody um only the rich benefit from
capitalism uh capitalism being the
control of a state apparatus or a nation
government state whatever word you use
by a certain class so if rich people are
those are that class and they control
that state is the government that nation
of course they're the ones to benefit
from
them talk to the abyss looks like it it
seems like a Tik
Tok you guys disagree yeah you want me
to explain why first before you go so
I'm Marxist so I believe that Society
through class struggles transitions
through different epochs or different
modes of production different economic
systems so I believe that the Civil War
was a revolutionary war in America that
transitioned us out of the slave-based
mode of production in in the annabellum
South into capitalism I believe that
capitalism is a superior economic system
to slavery in Europe I believe
capitalism was a in many ways a superior
economic system to feudalism but I would
argue and and agree that capitalism is
better for everybody than say slavery
like you can still rise from the bottom
with capitalism and that's most
societies so it's like this is possible
for you know the less wealthy to climb
to the Top If they have a good idea or
like innovate on something that they
think is a good concept we're talking
about benefits right no I I see your
both your points um definition I know
now I'm being empathetic I was telling
you not to give you a definition I'm
about to give you a definition Capital
we should establish definitions things
we talking we got to be on the same page
I feel like when it comes to science and
ideology it just gets kind of messy it's
more it's I feel like it's just so much
easier to do logical like if you site a
definition I'll accept whatever you give
me I don't know about these guys n this
is a trap hold on let me finish this but
my idea of capitalism um I very much
look at it within again very material
very cemented the idea of who has
control over the military judicial
legislative arm of a Nation or a state
for an episode about capitalist
communist we have not talked that class
whatever class has control within that
nation and now capitalism would be the
rich the Bazi the the the the job
creators having complete control within
that Society of course that would only
benefit rich people of course you're
going to get of course you're going to
push for taxk cuts of course you're
never going to talk about livable wage
you'll talk about minimum wage it's harm
reduction it's a tricky one I'm not sure
there's ever a time when wealth doesn't
concentrate up including Stalin ma dong
popot it's all Castro
you don't think Castro was a rich man
who was benefited from the Cuban system
didn't you have almost a billion dollars
di but I want to interject real fast
because unlike C I won't just accept
definitions so when we talk about
capitalism that's fine that's your
definition but for most people when we
say capitalism what we mean is the free
exchange and selling and buying of goods
right and the more you have of that the
more freedom you have in those decisions
the less the government's involved in
that the more capitalism you have and as
we have seen capitalism expand across
the world over the past 30 40 50 years
we have seen an 80% reduction in World
poverty since
1990 alone it was cut in half between
1990 and 2010 that's miraculous we have
also seen a 40% reduction in child labor
we have seen the mortality rate for
children cut in half we've seen the
maternal mortality rate Fall by like 43%
we work fewer hours at it blows my mind
that somebody could say only the rich
benefit from capitalism what evidence
you have that capitalism because these
not
China's the Bel because we're measuring
as capitalism has moved into various
countries and we're looking at their
poverty rates and their hunger rates by
the way get cut as more and more
socialist and communist countries have
fallen which by the way we're down to
only five at this point because most
people are turning against it as that
has happened largely since 1993 we've
seen more countries become democracies
more countries Implement capitalism and
yes sometimes it's like implemented the
Bel Road their uh in their poverty
alleviation programs though so what
evidence you have that's not having an
effect that's when they did what launch
their poverty alleviation programs in
the Belton Road initiative which are in
are intended to build up um
industrialization in countries who have
been prevented from advancing their
productive forces by imperialism
economic sanctions and the US dominated
Financial system that emerged after
World War II where the IMF and the World
Bank can basically decide whoever they
want to give financing to so like when
Chile went socialist under Salvador
aende um Richard Nixon famously said
make the economy screen and the IMF and
World Bank went from giving them $200
million in funding a year to two why do
communist countries always have to
depend on capitalist countries to
succeed anytime they don't it's because
there was an embargo or they weren't
giving them money I don't hear us saying
that about North Korea the Congo is
capitalist the Congo is one of the
poorest countries in the world the Congo
though is mineral Rich so much Cobalt
every single one of your folds needs
cbol to work that is your real life
vibranium capitalism has not helped the
Congo the disorder within the country
benefits the capitalist at home say
capitalist what do you mean that the
Congo is capitalist well you better
defition if you're African you know who
the new colonizers are China who's
extracting resources Out of Africa Ty I
love you terrible argue with me great
with great with the other just because
you say it's terrible doesn't mean it's
ter to be clear I'm not I wouldn't
accept your definition of capitalism but
I will obviously accept your definition
of socialism that's what I meant like
obviously I know what I think capitalism
my definition is social
why is China why do we think are you
making the stance that supposed
altruistic SL centrally governed China
is not a new capitalistic Empire moving
into Dubai you see it there moving into
Africa China is not America there are
clear differences what America does in
the Congo versus what China does America
comes in they set up military bases
unmarked airplanes will come into the
Congo with multitudes of American
Military and multiple corporations you
know what China does they come in with
intellectuals with a document signing
would you guys like to do this trade
deal if you do this we'll build a Mining
facility that the state can run and that
will benefit your taxes and you know
what the Congo will say they'll say no
you know what China will do they make a
new deal you know what happens when you
say no to
America you cut
off there's no perfect economic
model there's no disagree or there I
mean one of the sorry start already one
of the main misconceptions about
Communists is that we want to establish
a Utopia one of the foundational
communist texts is Friedrich Engel
socialism utopian and scientific where
he says he criticizes these utopian
socialists who are saying overnight
we're going to create this perfect
society says it's not possible you can
only build a better Society out of the
one you currently have so we have to
take what we currently have as far as a
socioeconomic structure and figure out
how we can build something better out of
that but it's never going to be utopian
there's always going to be problems
there's always going to be corruption
that needs to be combed we just um want
to build a system that's more rational
um and based on fulfilling human needs
and human flourishing rather than simply
profit so I think we would agree from
capitalism side that there's no perfect
system because there are scarcity of
resources and again I think you are
always up against human nature which has
a lot of corruption which has a lot of
selfishness a lot of self-interest why I
like capitalism is that I think it's a
system that acknowledges that and says
how do we restrain those impulses within
people how do we create a system where
in order for you to get what you want in
order for you to get your needs met in
order for you to get rich you have to
provide some kind of value for other
people and so that is what instigates
productivity that is why we see such
large Innovation gains we've seen such
big technological gains under capitalism
there's still going to be problems I
don't think there's any way to say we
will never have people who are poor we
will never have corruption but I think
capitalism does the best job of taking
what we're dealing with and trying to
make it operate in a system where people
are civil to one another and there's
natural cooperation within it when
people say when people say a perfect
economic system it's like saying what's
the perfect science communism Marx
Marxist leninism is a science what is
the most rational way to organize a
society to make sure that it can
actually see a future and if you read
the debates within the Chinese Communist
party they are constantly going Stalin
did this this was right this was wrong
you know Cuba did this Tito's Yugoslavia
they're constantly learning and
experimenting Stalin did wasn't open to
Too Much ideas but we're in 2023 St
let's talk about the mod countries
though because within the actual
communist countries right now you
literally have people going swimming
with sharks to escape them you don't see
that happening in capitalist countries
period one because you don't have to we
just let people leave when they want to
so that's a big part of it but two it's
because people know what's better for
them and they are getting out of
communist countries and DRS when they
can the two out of the five top
countries that are trying to immigrate
here right now are Cuba and Venezuela
people are starving under these systems
and so if you're a pragmatic person you
have to look at communism's track record
where it has killed millions of people
is the large it is the leading cause of
ideological death in the 20th century
and at some point you have to
acknowledge that I care about people I
want what's best for them but this isn't
doing it this isn't working they also
won't let you have a free press in any
of these countries they literally have a
government controlled press my Tik tok's
been banned seven times after the
US so there's no Free Press here either
St running Tik Tok it's still China no
it's no yes no you're wrong you're wrong
the US government forced Tik Tok to hand
over American servers to a company in
Texas called Oracle who proceeded to
hire a bunch of US state department
operatives and NATO operatives and
that's when we got banned so it's no
long no longer run by China it's almost
gone it's almost gone I'm just saying
there's no freedom of press in the US
either is freedom of the press what does
freedom mean in a country that imprisons
the most people in the world that's a
great question super opposed to it it
means that the government is too big
there's too many laws we make things
that are nonviolent have nothing to do
listen if I'm a capitalist I want to
protect people's person and their
property th those are the only laws that
should you're capitalist you protect the
property and property peoplehood and
their property individual liberty is
essential under C what are tax C you pay
everything that you're supposed to and
then they give you money back so you
have more money if there's a tax cut
right you have more money if more of
your money that they took that comes
back to okay so with those tax cuts that
just happened who has more of their
money what do you mean who has more of
their
money I got you which people gets to
keep more of their money who presume
it's the people making more money
obviously who makes the most profit if
there's a tax rate and you make more
money you're obviously going to pay more
money and if you get a tax cut you're
going to get more back because you made
more tax cuts for the rich or something
like that is that what you're talking
about well as a socialist I I'm not
really here to argue for taxes I'm more
to argue for worker ownership with the
means of production but I think bunny
wanted to go yeah I was going to ask so
I guess hypothetically in capitalism you
have free market correct so when free
market occurs it goes to near zero
profit correct when a free market occurs
it a free market the equilibrium point
is near zero profit because they'll keep
undercutting each other until they
maximize demand why would they work or
do anything classic economics yeah
classic economics um but let's say
hypothetically like Amazon is a prime
example they keep pricing like I guess
like earning less and less profit so
wouldn't that create monopolies and I
mean that's how you want to get more
Demand right okay so first of all like
capitalists are going to be generally
against like trust and monopolies but
all like at the same time like how how
could but how could no it does not every
time how or
allop how could a socialist AR yeah
exactly it's Rich to men when or
Communists argue against monopolies or
they use that as a hitting Point against
capitalists when like the biggest and
most powerful Monopoly that you could
possibly have is a state wa wait is a
state-owned monopoly yes it is
absolutely a monop how are you going to
break monop the state what apparatus is
going to come in and break and in a lot
of these can I make one point to in all
these socialist countries like Nicaragua
they're now investing in small business
and trying to encourage their civilians
to to start small businesses and to
innovate because they view that as a
better alternative than Monopoly and
what apparatus do you use to stimulate
small business and break up monopolies
besides the state and when the state
doing that it's not acting as a mon the
government creates so what about maybe
in the class struggle you had like you
said feudalism slavery capitalism we
tried communism maybe it's the rise of
Li is part of
capitalism slaves were Goods no
slaves government more than anything
inter in the free exchange of buying and
sell why does slavery predate capitalism
by thousands of years it's a part of
capitalism
why that's point I'd like to hear that
answer let's move on that cuz it's a Hot
Topic it's too spicy it's not your term
I want to respond you wanted to make
that point you cannot say I don't want I
you do want to argue you wanted to make
your point so let me make it back Hannah
and then you're going to try to say it's
too spicy for me no I got you like let
me respond to you it is not capitalism
coming in and shrining enslavement it
has been on the books in multiple kinds
of countries multiple economic systems
throughout history and in fact
capitalism is what got rid of it this
country is what turned the tide on that
and started pushing back against the
centuries old awful institution so to
say it's capitalism I think it's
honestly offensive that's
ridiculous the purpose of an economy
should be to maximize the well-being of
the
population hey that was my
problem no disagree what happens if no
one disagrees I knew we'd agree on this
there no debate when we were I knew we
were going to be debating capitalists I
figured none of you would defend
Monopoly capitalism you'd be more Pro
small business more Pro free enterprise
and you know you look at our current
American system and it's not like ideal
you know you're not giving it to thumbs
up so yeah I just think we we all agree
that we're trying to find the best
economic system to promote flourishing
among society and the population an
economic system has the responsibility
of taking care of their systems that's
common sense shouts out to Thomas pay I
me seems pretty
kind of self-explanatory at this point
the government should always or in
general the society should strive to be
better and to make lives better for
everyone but I would say not the
government I think you need smaller
government seems to mess everything up
know with you humans if you talk about
the flourish you can still see there's
tribes that live more Hunter gather
small I think smaller is better about a
robot what about unbias there's an anime
called psychop pass which okay okay you
guys don't know okay perfect so I think
a centralized brain computer with
multiple like millions and millions of
Minds in it might be more efficient so a
bigger government might be more
efficient if we could actually pull it
off like Psychopaths I think it would
work who programs the big computer well
at some point AI can think for itself
but right now with AI development though
because the way it starts to gather its
information is by absorbing what's
already out there so they're already
having so many issues with AI being
sexist being racist starting to have
really toxic views so I think that it's
um it's a nice utopian dream right I get
your point but to me I would never trust
anybody or any piece of Machinery to
come in and run our our goal is to get
worker ownership of the means means of
production and worker control of
production so I actually agree with what
you're saying and one of my buddies
Christopher halali is a is a communist
farmer in Virginia and he lives in a
very similar Community to you and you
know he says the same thing workers
should be able to make these decisions
about when to harvest you know but they
can't do that if all the farmland and
all the the Farming tools and tractors
are and fertilizers owned by
multinational corporations and big Agra
business I would like to note that you
said control rather than own and I think
that under a capitalist system workers
do control the means of production by
using their money as indicators right
like the business owners produce Things
based on the demand that consumers or
workers or the same thing have our
dollar doesn't mean our dollar does mean
something it's an indicator for what
things are valued at but if a central
decided sorry go ahead yeah if a central
decid if the central government just
decides what it's worth like they have
no indicat surpluses because price is
just a signal of scarcity longm hey
there's not things of this so the price
is going to go up or hey we've got a
surplus of this so the price is going to
come down it's a signal to people and it
signals scarcity if you remove that
signal that's why centralized economies
fail because there's no way sources
there's no economic calculation like and
and then you have the situation where
people have to go into the black market
to get things that they need it creates
utter chaos versus Under capitalism you
have this free flow of goods based on
the signals that are going out between
merchants and purchasers it's all very I
I would say that any capitalist would
agree that the ability to just quit your
job and suffered through the demeaning
Act of trying to find another one is not
a great example of Freedom within this
country why I don't understand very easy
to quit your job another job it's not
difficult it sure the average person who
decides to quit a menial job who has no
access to education to get them a higher
paying job who has no who has who has no
social connection no Culture Connection
no State apparatus helping them real
life just pure real life it's not as
easy as turn off turn on this leads to
another really great example of
government intervention that really
screws up you brought up education
pretty much anyone in the United States
can get in college no matter how
terrible your that's great that really
leads me to my next Point cheap it is
very expensive but do you know why
people are able to go to college despite
the fact that it's super expensive
because the federal government comes in
and says hey I've got two bags of money
right here and I'm will give it all to
you even though I know you can't pay it
back and then the colleges say well hey
guys you know it seems when we keep
raising our prices the government just
keeps paying it and the kid we don't
even have to worry about if the kids are
able to pay it back we're just going to
keep on paying it the trend line for
like college tuition prices and like
government involvement in the education
system especially on the Collegiate
level is like identical what does
government do well we forgot to ask up
capital and prob Banks but then you
don't like government then we all agree
we don't like
government
like we shce to meet
you I went to shake your hand you were
face the other way don't leave me
[Music]
hanging